thank you for coming along I'm sorry to
break into your half term
break
being fertilizer of Scotland is in my
admittedly biased opinion the very best
job in the world
it is a privilege Beyond major
one that has sustained and inspired me
in good times and through the toughest
hours of my toughest days
I am proud to stand here as the first
female and longest serving incumbent of
this office
and I'm very proud of what has been
achieved in the years I've been in Butte
house
however since my very first moments in
the job
I have believed that part of serving
well would be to know
almost instinctively when the time is
right to make way for someone else
and when that time came to have the
courage to do so even if to many across
the country and in my party it might
feel too soon
in my head and in my heart I know that
time is now
that it is right for me for my party and
for the country
and so today I am announcing my
intention to step down as first Minister
and leader of my party
I have asked the national Secretary of
the SNP to begin the process of electing
a new party leader and I will remain in
office until my successor is elected
I know there will be some across the
country who feel upset by this decision
and by the fact I am taking it now
of course for balance there will be
others who will how should I put this
cope with the news just fine
such as the beauty of democracy
but to those who do feel
shocked disappointed
perhaps even a bit angry with me please
know that how hard
and being no doubt this is really hard
for me my decision comes from a place of
Duty and of love
tough love perhaps but love nevertheless
for my party and above all for the
country
let me set out as best as I can my
reasons
first though I know it will be tempting
to see it as such this decision is not a
reaction to short-term pressures
of course there are difficult issues
confronting the government just now but
when is that ever not the case I have
spent almost three decades in Frontline
politics a decade and a half on the top
or second top rung of government
when it comes to navigating choppy
Waters resolving seemingly intractable
issues or soldiering on when walking
away would be the simpler option I have
plenty of experience to draw on
so if this was just a question of my
ability or my resilience to get through
the latest period of pressure I wouldn't
be standing here today but it's not
this decision comes from a deeper and
longer term assessment
I know it might seem sudden but I have
been wrestling with it albeit with
oscillating levels of intensity for some
weeks
essentially I've been trying to answer
two questions
is carrying on right for me
and more importantly is me carrying on
right for the country for my party and
for the independence cause I have
devoted my life to
I understand why some will automatically
answer yes to that second question
but in truth I have been having to work
harder in recent times to convince
myself that the answer to either of them
when examined deeply is yes and I've
reached the difficult conclusion that
it's not
the questions are inextricably linked
but let me try
I've been first Minister for over eight
years
and I was Deputy first minute for the
minister for the best part of eight
years before that
these jobs are a privilege but they are
also rightly hard and especially in the
case of first Minister relentlessly so
now to be clear I'm not expecting
violins here but I am a human being as
well as a politician
when I entered government in 2007
my niece and youngest nephew were babies
just months old as I stepped down
they're about to celebrate their 17th
birthdays
now that I think about it that's exactly
the age to be horrified at the thought
of your auntie suddenly having more time
for you
my point is this giving absolutely
everything of yourself to this job is
the only way to do it the country
deserves nothing less
but in truth that can only be done by
anyone for so long for me it is now in
danger of becoming too long
the first minister is Never Off Duty
particularly in this day and age there
is virtually no privacy
even ordinary stuff that most people
take for granted like going for a coffee
with friends or for a walk in your own
becomes very difficult
and the nature and form of modern
political discourse means that there is
a much greater intensity did I see it
brutality to Life as a politician than
in Years Gone by
all in all
and actually for a long time without it
being a parent it takes its toll on you
and on those around you
in fact it's true in the best of times
it has been more so in recent years
leading this country through the covert
pandemic is by far the toughest thing
I've done
it may well be the toughest thing I ever
do I certainly hope so
Now by no stretch of the imagination was
my job the hardest in the country during
that time
with the weight of responsibility was
immense
and it's only very recently I think that
I've started to comprehend let alone
process the physical and mental impact
of it on me
so what I'm really seeing is this if the
only question was can I battle on for
another few months then the answer is
yes of course I can
but if the question is can I give this
job everything it demands and deserves
for another year let alone for the
remainder of this parliamentary term
give it every ounce of energy that it
needs in the way that I have strived to
do every day for the past eight years
the answer honestly is different
and as that is my conclusion hard though
it has been for me to reach it then
given the nature and scale of the
challenges the country faces I have a
duty to say so now
I feel about Duty first and foremost to
our country to ensure that it has the
energy of leadership that it needs not
just today but through the years that
remain of this parliamentary term
and right now in a very particular sense
I feel that duty to my party too
we are at a critical Moment The Blocking
of a referendum is the accepted
constitutional route to Independence is
a democratic outrage but it puts the
onus on us to decide how Scottish
democracy will be protected and to
ensure that the will of the Scottish
people prevails my preference of using
the next Westminster election as a de
facto referendum is well known I've
never pretended it is perfect no second
best option ever is nor that there are
no alternatives
that is why I've always been clear that
the decision must be taken by the SNP
collectively not by me alone
but I know my party well enough to
understand that my view as leader would
carry enormous probably decisive weight
when our conference meets next month
and I cannot in good conscience ask the
party to choose an option based on my
judgment whilst not being convinced that
I would be there as a leader to see it
through
but making my decision clear now I free
the SNP to choose the path it believes
to be the right one without worrying
about the perceived implications for my
leadership and in the knowledge that a
new leader will Steed us I believe
successfully on that path
now there are two for the reflections
that have weed in my decision
these I suppose I'm more about our
political culture and the nature and
impact of the dominance and Longevity
that come from success and politics
the first I hope my party will take
heart from
one of the difficulties in coming to
terms with this decision is that I am
confident that I can and would lead the
SNP to further electoral success
we remain by far the most trusted party
in Scotland
and while for every person in Scotland
who loves me there is another who let's
say might not be quite so enthusiastic
we are firmly on course to win the next
election while our opponents remain
adrift
but the longer any leader is in office
the more opinions about them become
fixed and very hard to change and that
matters
individual pools come and go but I am
firmly of the view that there is no
majority support for Independence in
Scotland
but that support needs to be solidified
and it needs to grow further if our
independent Scotland is to have the best
possible Foundation
to achieve that we must reach across the
divide in Scottish politics
and my judgment now is that a new leader
will be better able to do this someone
about whom the mind of almost everyone
in the country is not already made up
for better or worse someone who is not
subject to quite the same polarized
opinions fear or unfair as I know am
the good news as the country will now
get to see more clearly perhaps is that
the SNP is full of talented individuals
more than up to that task
my second
reflection is related
you know I feel more and more each day
now that the fixed opinions people
increasingly have about me as I say some
fear others little more than caricature
are being used as barriers to reason
debate in our country
statements and decisions that should not
be controversial at all quickly become
so issues that are controversial end up
almost irrationally so
too often I see issues presented and as
a result viewed not on their own merits
but through the prism of what I think
and what people think about me
I've always been of the belief that no
one individual should be dominant in any
system for too long
but while it's easy to hold that view in
the abstract it is much harder to live
by with this decision I am trying to do
so
indeed if all parties were to take this
opportunity to depolarize public debate
just a bit to focus more on issues than
on personalities
and to reset the tone and the tenor of
our discourse
then this decision right for me and I
believe in my party in the country might
also prove to be good for our politics I
certainly live in Hope
now a couple of final points before I
take a few questions while I am stepping
down from leadership I am not leaving
politics there are many issues I care
deeply about and hope to Champion in
future one of these is the promise the
national Mission so close to my heart to
improve the life chances of care
experience young people and ensure they
grew up nurtured and loved my commitment
to these young people will be lifelong
and obviously there is independence
winning Independence is the cause I have
dedicated a lifetime to it is a cause I
believe in with every fiber of my being
and it is a cause I am convinced as
being one I intend to be there as it is
one every step of the way
yesterday morning I attended the funeral
of a very very dear friend and
long-standing Independence activist a
wonderful man by the name of Alan Angus
it was actually
during that funeral service that I went
from being 99 certain about this
decision to a hundred percent certain
though I know Alan would not be at all
happy to have played any part in my
departure so I'm sorry Alan
but his funeral reminded me that the
cause of Independence is so much bigger
than any one individual the all of us
who believe in it contribute in
different ways at different stages of
Our Lives
since I was 16 I have contributed as an
activist a campaigner and a leader and
so now as we look to what I firmly
believe is the final stage in Scotland's
journey to Independence albeit a hard
one I hope to use all the experience and
perspective I've gathered over these
years to help get us there
lastly there will be time in the days to
come for me and others to reflect on
what has been achieved during my time as
first Minister I'm pretty certain there
will be plenty of commentary on my
mistakes as well
I will have more to say before I admit
office but allow me some brief
Reflections now
Scotland is a changed country since 2014
and in so so many ways it has changed
for the better
young people from deprived backgrounds
have never had a better chance of going
to University than now our investment to
double Early Learning and child care is
transforming opportunities for the
youngest children it's also enabling
more women to return to work the baby
box is enshrining our aspiration that
every child should have the best starts
in life
Scotland is fairer today than it was in
2014. we have a more Progressive
approach to Taxation and a new social
security system with the Scottish child
payment at its heart
as the institute for fiscal studies
confirmed last week the Buddhist
families with children in Scotland are
now two thousand pounds better off as a
result of our policies Germany in this
cost of living crisis that will be the
difference between food and the table
and a warm home or not
there are stronger protections for
victims of domestic abuse and Parliament
will soon consider legislation to
improve access to justice for victims of
rape and sexual offenses I will be the
strongest possible advocate for these
reforms from the back benches
we've also shown over these past few
years what can be done with the full
powers of a Nation creating institutions
are part of the transition to becoming
independent you tax and social security
agencies a network of trade hubs across
the world and a state-owned Investment
Bank ready to help the country reap the
industrial benefits of our vast
renewable resources there is so much
that I am proud of
but there is always so much more to be
done I look forward to watching with
pride as my successor picks up the Baton
there will also be time in the days to
come for me to say thank you to a very
very long list of people without whom I
would not have lasted a single day in
this job late alone eight years
I won't do so today
I might inadvertently forget someone or
perhaps more likely start to cry
but there are a couple of exceptions
firstly my husband and family
a few people understand the price
families of politicians pay for the jobs
we choose to do
mine have been my walk throughout
and of course the SNP since I was 16
years old you have been my extended
family thank you for the honor of being
your leader
and it seems to me that eight emphatic
election victories in eight years Ain't
a Bad record together
finally and above all
the people of this beautiful talented
diverse at times disputatious but always
wonderful country
we Face the toughest of times together
I did everything I could to guide us
through that time
often from my very familiar podium in
Saint Andrews house
then return I was sustained through that
period by a wave of support from you
that I will remember and value for the
rest of my life
so to the people of Scotland
to all of the people of Scotland whether
you've voted for me or not please know
that being your first Minister has been
the privilege of my life nothing
absolutely nothing I do in future will
ever come anywhere close
thank you from the very bottom of my
heart
and with that
I will take a few questions
if you forgive me I'm not going to do my
usual and go around absolutely every
journalist in the room there will be
time over the next few weeks I'm sure
for you all to ask me questions but I'll
take a few questions uh for now and I'll
start with Glen Campbell from the BBC
first Minister if you can't lead
Scotland to Independence sorry first
minute so if you can't lead Scotland to
Independence who if anyone can and what
is the timetable now for your
replacement and on a slightly lighter
note do you know all Douglas Ross 100
pounds as a result of a bet
I think it was 50. so if he's already
inflated it to 100
you have words there
um I will let Mr Ross have the bet at my
party will keep winning the elections
um on your other questions on the
timetable that's a matter for the SNP
national executive committee I'm sure it
will send out the timetable for the
election of a new SNP leader over the
coming days
um and I will demit office when my
successor has been elected and then
obviously subject to the will of
parliament uh elected as the new first
Minister
um I and this is a question that no
matter how many times you ask it of me
over the next few weeks no matter how
many inventive ways you find of asking
it I am not going to say who my
preference will be to succeed me what I
do know is that the SNP is Awash with
talented individuals one of the things
that I've often reflected on
um is that when a political party early
political party in any country has very
dominant individuals others through no
fault of the dominant individual I
should see and know sometimes for the
want of trying often others become a bit
eclipsed there so what I am looking
forward to and I think the country will
enjoy over these next few weeks is
seeing that Talent
um and seeing the array of talent I
believe I have led this country closer
to Independence I believe we are in the
Final Phase of that journey I think it
will be hard because now we have the
Dual challenge the one we always had of
convincing a majority a solid
sustainable majority of the merits of
Independence but also secondly a
challenge that is new of finding in the
face of Westminster anti-democratic
opposition that Democratic route to
allowing the will of the Scottish people
to be expressed and I believe that my
successor I firmly believe that my
successor whoever he or she may be will
lead Scotland to Independence and I'll
be there cheering him or her own every
single step of the way
thanks first Minister
um you see that you've been wrestling
with this decision for a number of weeks
now and it's not in reaction to some
issues over the last couple of weeks
couple of months do you believe though
that the issues are in particularly the
row around transgender prisoners was the
straw that broke the camel's back here
and second of all has it been a failure
of your leadership not to have delivered
Independence since that was your sort of
founding Mission back in 2014. I'll
leave other people to be the judge of my
leadership it's probably a bit in videos
Beyond seeing what I'm proud of and
taking this country ever closer to
Independence is one of those things it's
a bit in videos for me to to cast that
judgment no that issue wasn't the final
Story look I'm I'm long enough in the
truth I've been in politics as all of
you know for a long long time I'm not
going to stand here and insult your
intelligence and say that I live in a
world that is divorced from the
realities of what is going on around me
um but it's not the case that this
decision is because of short-term issues
I've faced more short-term issues from
time to time over my years in politics
than I cared to remember
um and if it was just that I wouldn't be
standing here today what I would say
though is this and I did allude to this
in my remarks I suppose when I look at
some of the issues that are being hotly
debated in Scotland right now one of the
things that I do regret I suppose is not
being able to bring a more rational
approach to these debates and I think
that goes back to some of what I said
earlier these debates some of them one
in particular right now is obviously
controversial in its own right but I
think later on to the top of that there
has been people's views about me about
independence and and suddenly debates
that should be rational and that we
should be capable as a country of having
rationally become something very
different and I will always be a voice
for in inclusion for Quality equality
for human rights and dignity and I have
been
um and will always be a feminist I will
fight for women's rights and I will
stand up against threats to women's
rights every day that I have breath in
my body but I'll also stand up for any
stigmatized discriminated against
marginalized and vulnerable group in
society and I believe in call me you
know an optimist not many people call me
an optimist but I am at heart an
optimist I believe these things can
create a must in any Progressive liberal
inclusive Society find ways of
coexisting
um and whatever role I play in politics
in the future I will always seek to do
everything I can to turn that into a
reality
how have you gone from having plenty in
the tank three weeks ago to an empty
tank today what is it that's changed
over the last few weeks you've mentioned
some things the only thing you didn't
mention is the police inquiry into the
party's finances
I sleep
these things are not the reason I'm
standing here today these are not
factors knowable my decision today
affect these things and all of these
things will will take the course
I I said something in my remarks
but I appreciate will divide opinion in
Scotland
um I'm a human being
and
every human being every day wrestles
with a whole load of
conflicting emotions
and over the last number of weeks
probably since around the time of the
year you know I've been struggling with
was just that you know I get up in the
morning and I I tell myself and usually
I convince myself that I've got what it
takes to keep going and keep going and
keep going um but then I realized that's
maybe not as true and and you go through
a process of just deciding where it is
and that decision you're going to fall
and and that's the decision I've come to
today I could go on for another few
months I don't know what six months a
year maybe but I know that as time
passed I would have less and less energy
to give to the job and I can't do the
job
on anything other than a 100 basis the
country deserves nothing less than that
so that's a judgment I've come to if
that's my feeling that I'm going to get
in a relatively short space of time to
where I am today then I went to the
country to see it now so that that new
leadership can be in place and as I said
in relation to my party I don't want to
stand at a special conference
um what a month or so from now and asked
my party to take my judgment
opt for a path
knowing that I have doubts about my
ability to see it through as leader this
is a better thing to do today for me for
my party and I believe for the country
too James quick
first minister
I think it's fair to say that the NHS is
in a really serious situation
the attainment gap between rich and poor
pupils which you'd said was one of your
core missions as first Minister remains
pretty wide
and despite what you're saying today
Paul suggests that you have got nowhere
near creating a sustained majority for
Independence
do you have regrets about one or any of
those issues oh again James I'm a human
being I don't know if you've got regrets
about things in your life of course I've
got regrets about all sorts of things in
my life and as I reflect in my time this
first minute so there'll be things I am
hugely proud of
um and things that I regret and if I had
my time again I might do differently and
forgive me there'll be plenty of time
for me to do that though I'm sure it'll
be plenty of time for you to do that and
I'm sure you will
um so yeah but I'm proud of my time as
first Minister and but I'm also proud
that I know when it's time to move on
and to pass on to someone else
um the country because I believe in my
party
everything is bigger than any politician
no matter who they are and no matter how
dominant they've been for no matter how
much time you know poll sessions come
and go home all the time the country
is what matters and the future of the
country is what matters I'm proud of the
part I have played and hope to continue
to play in a different capacity in
building the future of this country but
I think in terms of leadership it's time
for someone else I think the easier
sometimes thing to do and the thing that
traditionally politicians tend to do is
should cling on and on and on and on and
on until you know everybody is sort of
pushing for you to go it's it's harder
because there's always reasons not to
yeah if I stay a bit longer I can do
this if I stay a bit longer you know
something might happen it's always
easier to find the reasons not to make a
decision I think it's better to make the
decision when you know in your heart
that it's the right one for you if
you're country I'm
sure I won't see the sentence actually I
will be 53 this year
um I entered Parliament you know when I
was fought at 29 I've been in government
since I was 37. I have literally done
this in one capacity or another for all
of my life I've been Nicholas urgent the
politician for all of my life it's been
a privilege I have done things met
people gone places had experiences I
would never have done I have a depth of
gratitude to the party that I lead to
the country that I serve that I can
never find the words to express but I
haven't reached this stage in my life
maybe I want to spend a bit of time on
Nicholas Dodge in the person the human
being and contribute differently and
does that sound in some ways selfish I
hope it doesn't because I have given and
will in whatever way I can continue to
give everything I can in service to this
country but I need for me and I think
it's right for the country to do that in
a different way in future and that is
what I'm seeking to do and the more I
talk the more convinced I am that this
is the right decision for me
um I'll take Louise Scott from ITV I'm
going to end up doing what I said I
wouldn't do I don't know I'm not going
to do that Louise first Minister we've
heard Rumblings of Divisions within the
party in recent weeks particularly
around certain issues ultimately did you
lose trust in your leadership from
certain key members of your party
I think you'd have to ask individuals to
give the views of my leadership I think
any objective analysis would suggest
that that's not true you know I'd enjoy
you know the risk of sounding in
modestier which as you know I never like
to do
um but yeah I even in
times that would be described have been
described by most of you as tough yeah I
enjoy approval ratings after eight years
in government that most leaders would
give the right arm for
um so you know yes of course the longer
any leader is in office the more people
will find things to disagree with you on
because nobody agrees with any other
person 100 and
that concept of uh or you know that
whole idea of longevity in politics the
longer you lead the more you know you
will you will find issues that people
find it hard to give with you on but you
know I believe I could if it was just
about can I lead this party country
forward uh certainly the party to
Electro success the answer is yes but it
is much deeper than that which is what
I've been trying to give a sense off
today
uh who we have next Kieran Jenkins
first Mr you said judge me on my record
didn't you you remember saying that in
the context of the education
entertainment gap between the the best
and the worst off pupils
now is surely the time to do that do you
think you failed those young people no I
don't made a promise you didn't deliver
it the NHS is in a pretty perilous State
drugs deaths have been catastrophic when
you look back do you wish it were
different you could have been more
successful in those areas in which you
have had complete or considerable
control well I'll refer back to a
question when
about you know anybody taking stock of
the the things of proud of the things
they wish they could turn the court back
and do differently and I'll do that and
and you know you use the terms judge me
one thing I can be absolutely certain of
is people will judge me and there's been
no shortage of judgments on me and you
know what I've done or not done in
office and I'm pretty certain that will
continue but if you take young people
and today
and I remember possibly including by you
but certainly by plenty in this room
being challenged on this when I became
first Minister about the attainment Gap
in access to University today we pretty
much were on track to close that if
you're a young person from a deprived
background or a background right the one
I come from you've got a better chance
than you've ever had before of going to
University at the other end of the
education system that fundamental
investment in expansion doubling early
years child care and education is
transformational it effects won't be
seen immediately but the effects that
will have as children go through the
school system are considerable the NHS
everywhere
um health services are under pressure
this country is the only one in the UK
that has not faced industrial action in
our health service because of our
approach to working with those in the
service together in Partnership to
tackle these challenges and that will
continue and so you on a whole range of
these things I'll have plenty plenty of
time to reflect at greater length and
I'm pretty certain all of you will
reflect it at length
um but
one thing is for sure there will be no
shortage of of judgment on me and my
time as first minister
right we take a couple more
um and Alan Smith from Burger is the
next one
thank you first Minister you spoke about
this has been something you've been
thinking about a matter of weeks and not
in response to short-term pressures but
at what point did you start to consider
was there a particular moment those
weeks ago and who did you have
conversations with at that time about
whether or not this is the right
decision to take
and I've been thinking about it I used
the term in my remarks with oscillating
intensity you know and that's that's
true you know there are some days you
know I mean I thought about that talk is
frankly too much else and then other
times it's it's weighed more heavily I I
don't know you know possibly a couple
weeks ago it just started to to
crystallize a bit more but inevitably
again here's the the human thing it
always takes you a bit of time I think
to between the point where
probably deep down inside you've made a
decision and been able to actually admit
that to yourself before you even start
telling other people so I couldn't
pinpoint the exact moment except that
certain in uh the funeral service for
Alan yesterday
surrounded by SMP members mourning
somebody that you know 89 years old had
campaigned all his life for Independence
it it did have that clarifying effect
that you know stepping down as leader
doesn't mean I stop contributing to the
cause of Independence it doesn't mean
you start making a contribution
everybody has their time
and I think in leadership one of the
hardest but one of the most important
things to do is nowhere in that time is
up in terms of who I talked about it
obviously my close family the
a small number of friends you know one
of the things in in leadership you
really really do learn is who your true
friends are in life and you know so if
you're one of the the small number who
mainly because I wouldn't have been able
to tell you without crying over the last
24 hours I didn't phone but texting this
morning just before the news broke uh no
year one of those friends and and thank
you for all your support
and a new person from PA
thanks first Minister uh first of all
can you just confirm us you'll be
staying on as an MSP and what kind of
issues you'll be campaigning on as an
MSP and also will the cooperation
agreement with the Scottish green party
need to be renegotiated now if you as
first Minister are no longer in that
role
and I at the cooperation agreement
stands I'm not going to try to dictate
uh anything or at this stage something
or uh now and hopefully not ever start
to issue on solicited advice to my
successor I I know from experience
that's not always something that is
welcome
um
don't report that but
but you know I think the cooperation
agreement with the greens has been a
thoroughly good thing um for the
government for the country and I I would
hope to see that uh continue your first
question which I understood oh yes I do
intend to remain in Parliament I hope to
stay in Parliament till I tend to stay
in Parliament too certainly the next
election and you know like all msps take
a decision about beyond that near the
the time of the next election
um
you know the other
a body of people I suppose that I want
to thank and was hesitant in doing it
today in case I started to cry as are my
constituents uh who have supported me
through thick and thin put the trust in
me time and again my constituency party
uh what was Glasgow Governor Glasgow so
say that have literally been by my side
since 1995 and I look forward to
continuing to serve my constituency to
the best of my ability I've given some
indication of the kind of issues I'll
want to be a voice on uh there's some
very important reforms to the criminal
justice system coming forward I know
around improving access to justice for
victims of sexual offenses I will be
they'll be controversial maybe they
could be one of the first tests of a a
more depolarized political debate but I
will be the strongest most strenuous
advocate for these reforms young people
care experienced young people I
certainly will continue to Champion that
cause it's one that got under my skin
and into my heart in a way that few
others is that over my time as first
minister
um and yeah beyond that uh we will see
um I'm looking forward to New
Opportunities new challenges
um and just a new way of living life and
perhaps and above all else that's what
I'm most looking forward to just a
different way of living life catching up
with the people with friends and that
I've not had much opportunity to spend
time with
um but watch this space there's plenty
minutes to come right with that I'm
going to department is it just a one
factual point Have You Been or do you
expect to be interviewed by the police
who are looking into your participants
I'm not going to discuss an ongoing
police investigation I wouldn't do that
on any issue and I'm not going to do it
now